im finnischen Lapland direkt am
nördlichen Polarkreis stehen die Chancen
echt gut nachts im Winter Polarlichter
zu sehen und wo geht das besser als
mitten im Nirgendwo ganz alleine in der
Wildnis in einem dieser überteuerten
Outdoor Iglus die Du bestimmt von tiktok
kennst ich habe uns für eine Nacht dort
eingebucht und ich muss sagen es war
echt ein tolles Erlebnis was ich so
schnell nicht vergessen werde irgendwer
Bock auf Meet and Greet mit
Weihnachtsmann ist da wirklich ein
Weihnachtsmann drin e da ist ja wirklich
ein Weihnachtsmann wieso das das ist ja
echte Weihnachtsmann nein richtiges der
ist echt the one and only legendary
Christmas man himself und damit Leute
herzlich Willkommen zu Tag 1 aus roban
yemi wir sind gerade noch im City Center
fahren jetzt gleich aber zu unserer
Unterkunft und das wird denke ich echt
richtig geil das sage ich irgendwie in
der Vergangenheit oft dass irgendwas
geil wird ja ist eigentlich ein gutes
Zeichen oder also irgendwie habe ich mir
so diese
weihnachtsmannstadt schon anders
vorgestellt weil das sieht hier alles
halt also so schön ist das jetzt nicht
wobei hier kann man wenigstens schitschu
laufen das war schon mal etwas wir
kaufen jetzt auf jeden Fall eben noch
ein hier im Supermarkt weil in unserem
Iglo gibt es eigentlich nicht viel außer
vielleicht Frühstück haben und irgendwas
müssen wir heute Abend auch noch essen
ich weiß nicht ob wir dann ein
wasserkoch haben keine Ahnung schön Bo
die sind aber echt clean so ich habe
jetzt ein uber bestellt und damit fahren
wir jetzt zu unserem Iglo hin es ist
gerade mal 14:30 Uhr aber es ist schon
wieder fast dunkel das ist echt ein
bisschen schade hier und ich finde man
ist dadurch auch immer ein bisschen müde
weil man hat halt nur so 3 Stunden am
Tag wo es wirklich hell ist und sonst
ist so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tomorrow night
not
okay so hier geht's jetzt rein also wir
sind hier wirklich m
nirgendwo
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dr thank
you angekommen irgendwo im Nirgendwo
also hier ist wirklich okay da ist ein
Haus hier ist eine Hütte und da oben
sind glaube ich auch noch so kleine
panoramahütten aber da schlafen wir
nicht drin sondern da unten eigentlich
ist da ein Fluss aber der ist zugefroren
dann gehen wir mal runter würde ich
sagen e wie verrückt und was sagst du
das ist so krass das ein okay es gibt h
aber sogar zwei Iglus jetzt ist die
Frage
ARKTIK haben wir oder nee doch das
rechte ne würde ich auch sagen oh hier
war anscheinend schon länger keiner mehr
außer guck mal hier diese das könnte
doch von dem Wolf sein
oder die meinten zu uns wir können
natürlich auch den Grill benutzen ja
sieht ja super aus meinst du der ist
[Musik]
warm
doch geht riecht ein bisschen nach Chlor
so ist hier ein See ja das ist
eigentlich ein See oder ein Fluss ne ich
glaube das ist auch eigentlich ein Boot
dieses
[Musik]
Ding das ist so
schön ja schön warm stinkt als wä hier
so als wä das eigentlich ein
Rentierstall hier steht sogar ein Taxi
okay also das ist jetzt das Zimmer ich
zeig euch später auch noch mal was ich
dafür bezahlt habe wirklich geisteskrank
aber solange wir heute Nacht
Polarlichter sehen ist es okay finde ich
ey wie geil ich habe gerade geguckt ob
da nebenan Leute drin sind jetzt kommen
da hinten ein paar
Schneemobile warte mal
Alter ey wie cool schaut mal fahren
jetzt hier
lang so ist wahrscheinlich einfach so
eine schneemobiltour ich dachte das
wärden vielleicht die Besitzer und die
würden uns jetzt mal Guten Tag sagen
hier weil ich habe keine Ahnung wem das
gehört gehört und mit dem ich da
kommuniziert habe wir haben uns jetzt
kurz eingelebt erster Eindruck es ist
glaube ich echt der schönste Ort wo ich
je war ein Happ the happiest also ich
muss auch sagen super cool wir haben
jetzt gerade noch Nachbarn bekommen
nebenan ist ja noch ein anderes Iglo wir
machen eine kurze roomtour hier hinter
mir ist eine Kaffeemaschine ich konnte
endlich mal meine Kamera und mein Laptop
laden hier sind Steckdosen Waschbecken
kommt auch sogar bisschen Wasser
raus Schrank hier haben sie uns ein paar
Plätzchen geschenkt und ja das kann man
auch hochklappen hier seht ihr die
Toilette da ist einfach nur dieser
Vorhang vor hier ein Handtuch und ein
Bademantel für uns beide und Socken und
Socken und dahinter kann man einmal hier
die Temperatur einstellen hier genau wir
haben Stecker fürs Handy zum Aufladen
wir haben WLAN und ein Radio oder ja das
ist kein Fernseher glaube ich zum man
kann auf jeden Fall darüber Musik hören
ich bin echt gespannt es ist jetzt schon
dunkel wir haben kurz vor 4 Uhr ich
werde jetzt erstmal hier in diesen
kleinen Whirlpool da springen der ist
ziemlich warm stinkt aber auch extrem
nach Chlor aber egal ab rein da und dann
werden wir uns hier noch ein bisschen
entspannend hinlegen und warten dass es
halt ja dass wir halt schlafen können
weil was anderes haben wir auch nicht
mehr vor vor allen Dingen wir haben
jetzt 15:33 Uhr Leute und es fühlt sich
einfach so an als hten wir 10 Uhr bin
auch schon wieder total müde und ich
habe schon wieder Hunger also ausziehen
und ab da rein BAM Leute gebt euch das
wie geil oder da springt der Alex jetzt
rein und wenn ihr solche Videos feiert
wisst ihr was zu tun ist einfach den
Kanal abonnieren dann verpasst ihr
nichts mehr in nächste Zeit kommen noch
richtig geile Reiseprojekte und wir
gehen jetzt erstmal schwimmen jetzt
wird's kalt ich gehe da jetzt rein ne
ich mache die Tür zu alter -1°
mittlerweile da vorne sind übrigens
unsere Nachbarn da sind jetzt auch Leute
bin ich eigentlich ganz gut weil dann
sind wir nicht die einzigen hier in der
Wildnis ist kalt wow
Alter meine
Füße nicht hinfallen nicht hinfallen
Alter ist
das oh mein Gott boah Alter es war echt
kalt ist das
nice was ein geiler Ort wirklich man
muss sagen das Wasser ist wirklich sehr
sehr warm und angenehm
wow kann ich mir schön
Aufwärmen also ich muss wirklich sagen
rovemi Finnland generell Finnland das
Land auch Helsinki checkt auf jeden Fall
auch das letzte Video ab mit dem
polareexpress oder Lapland Express wo
wir von Helsinki nach rowanemi gefahren
sind kann ich jedem nur mal empfehlen
vor Weihnachten oder so das mal zu
machen echt geil und ich glaube hier
oben da ist ein Haus da wohnen auch
welche man hört da auf jeden Fall
[Musik]
was genug gebadet ich muss auch sagen
mir ist echt wahr mittlerweile eine
Sache die mir noch aufgefallen ist
schaut mal diese dicken eiszöpfen hier
dran das muss ich jetzt auch wieder
zuklappen wir haben erst 17 Uhr es sieht
aber schon aus wie mitten in der Nacht
und schaut mal da vorne klart der Himmel
auf der Taxifahrer meint ja zu uns heute
Nacht könnte man eigentlich schon
Polarlichter sehen da oben wird's auch
ein bisschen klarer also auch wenn es
nicht mega krass wird ich bin da guter
Dinge dass wir da irgendwie ein bisschen
was von sehen sonst wä echt schade aber
dafür sind wir ja auch hier ne okay dann
wollen wir
mal boah die Füße sind wirklich brutal
kalt nehmen wir mit Hilfe kalt e Alter
oh meine Füße GLB man wird da draußen
innerhalb von 2 Minuten
[Musik]
erfrieren mittlerweile ist es :24 Uhr
man muss sagen wir sind halt echt weit
vom Schuss und man kann hier nichts
machen außer ein bisschen vorm Iglo
rumstopfen in der Dunkelheit poicht
haben wir noch keine gesehen mach mal
bitte kurz das Licht aus ja aber der
Himmel sieht halt schon crazy aus das
muss man sagen auf der Kamera kommt
immer verdammt hell rüber so hell ist es
auch nicht Alter cool ich habe jetzt
gerade einfach doch Essen hier hin
bestellt ich bin mal gespannt ob das
ankommt weil hier steht ja auch drauf
Food Delivery Mobile App Volt delivery
to Iglo Arctic das habe ich alles
umgesetzt und ja eigentlich ganz geil
also ich hoffe mal der findet hier hin
ich habe mir noch überlegt Feuer draußen
zu machen aber es ist so arschkalt also
liegt das nicht du kannst ein ja das
also doch ich würde es glaube ich
schaffen aber es ist einfach zu kalt
also man muss eigentlich im Feuer
chillen so nachts ist das hier schön
beleuchtet okay und wenn ich Glück habe
ist da oben jetzt irgendwo unser Essen
also dass man hier essen hinbestellen
kann hät ich echt nicht
gedacht okay Leute es hat geklappt ich
habe ih jetzt 15 Minuten gesucht der hat
sich auch komplett Verfahren aber krass
das die bis hier hinliefern also in
Deutschland würden die safe sagen nee da
liefert halt einfach keiner hin oh Mann
der Tat mir jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen leid der hat mich die ganze
Zeit gesucht ich konnte den auch nicht
anrufen oder so na ja jetzt haben wir es
Hauptsache unsere
Nachbarn sind schön am Feuer machen und
wir kriegen es nicht hin und wir kriegen
es nicht hin ich habe jetzt auch echt
riesen Hunger wir haben jetzt hier
Burritos bist du dir sicher dass das
kein Fleisch ist ja ich kann es erst V
probieren
al so Soja trcks h oder mm glaub schon
m schaut mal dazu one Lapland dark
Lagerbier sehr gut und sch das n dass es
wirklich kein Fleisch ist ich auch W
noch mal gucken vegorizo ja aber willst
du wissen ob vegorizo vegetarisch heißt
dachte ich kann auch sein dass das
Rentierfleisch heißt stimmt vegane
Chorizo so das ist vegan vegan sogar
noch Marie aber lecker ne unsere
Nachbarn da
hinten die warten auch schon auf die
Polarlichter man kann immer noch nichts
sehen
ne noch ein kurzes Update wir haben
jetzt
22:56 Uhr im Internet steht die höchste
Chance für polarlechter ist so zwischen
18 uh 22 Uhr an einem klaren Tag und
eben war es auch mal kurzzeitig ein
bisschen klar aber leider hat sich jetzt
wieder ziemlich zugezogen auf der Kamera
sieht das alles so hell aus so hell ist
es echt nicht aber es ist schon trotzdem
ziemlich hell bin mittlerweile ein
bisschen skeptisch dass wir das wirklich
seh se vielleicht sollten wir auch mal
das Licht da ausmachen jetzt fängt auch
leicht an zu schneiden kannst du mal
gucken wie das
[Musik]
ausgeht ich leg mich jetzt auf jeden
Fall auch
hin vielleicht werden wir wach von den
Polar dann vielleicht auch nicht wenn
keine kommen dann logischerweise nicht
trotzdem auf eine entspannte Nacht gute
Nacht bis morgen
[Musik]
früh und damit guten Morgen motherfucker
eigentlich ganz gut geschlafen leider
haben wir keine Polarlichter gesehen
mittlerweile ist auch schon 10 Uhr wir
müssen gleich Auschecken 11 Uhr ist
Checkout time war echt richtig heiß in
dem Iglo drin also das hätte ich nicht
gedacht meine Nase ist auch bisschen zu
von dieser Heizungsluft da drin ja na ja
war trotzdem eine erholsam Nacht okay
Checkout time wir müssen raus und wie
fandst es sehr cool leider haben wir die
Polar sehen eine Sache muss ich noch
sagen und zwar wie viel ich dafür
bezahlt habe ja das hat pro Nacht also
wir haben jetzt eine Nacht bezahlt 604
EUR gekostet was natürlich geisteskrank
viel ist und ich muss auch sagen das ist
einfach zu teuer wenn man die
Polarlichter nicht sieht dann lohnt sich
das nicht trotzdem so hier ganz alleine
irgendwo im Nirgendwo ist das schon ganz
cool aber 600 € ist einfach geisteskrank
dafür meiner Meinung nach klar Finland
ist auch teuer aber das muss dann echt
nicht sein also checkt vorher online zu
wie viel Prozent Polarlichter kommen
wenn da steht 80 90% würde ich das
machen sonst kann man auch in geiles
Hotel gehen ne oder super abonniert den
Kanal Daumen nach oben wä geil Leute ich
hoffe das Video hat euch gefallen wir
können ruhig entgegen gehen unserem
Abholer ach Mensch ist do nicht weit
Däumchen nach oben wä geil haut rein
Leute ciao